يتواصلوا في اروقه السياسه الداخليه
التركيه الجدل بشان تعديلات قانونيه اقرها
البرلمان التركي مؤخرا لتنظيم النشر عبر
الانترنت ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
التعديلات شملت تغييرات على قانون الصحافه
وقوانين اخرى وجمعت ضمن حزمه قانونيه اطلق
عليها اسم قانون مكافحه المعلومات المضلله
تتضمن السجن ما بين عام الى ثلاثه اعوام
لمن ينشر معلومات كاذبه عن امن البلاد
الداخلي والخارجي والنظام العام والصحه
العامه بهدف اثاره القلق والذعر اضافه الى
تنظيم الحصول على البطاقه الصحفيه بما في
ذلك للعاملين في مواقع الاخبار
الالكترونيه وتنظيم عملي تلك المواقع ان
يبحثين يا ايمان هو رئيس لجنه الاعلام
الرقمي في البرلمان التركي ونائب عن حزب
العداله والتنميه الذي ترحم مشروع القانون
ما الذي جعلكم تشعرون بالحاجه الى مثل هذا
القانون المثير للجدل
اردنا هذا القانون لحمايه الديمقراطيه
والحريات والمعلومات الشخصيه والسلم
الاجتماعيه لن يدخل احد السجن بسبب تغريده
او منشور على مواقع التواصل من سيعاقب هو
من يظلل التظليل هو يكون الخبر كاذبا
ويكون متعلقا بامن الدوله والصحه العامه
وان يقصد منه اثاره الذعر بين الناس
في الصحف ومواقع الاخبار وبرامج الحوارات
التلفزيونيه انعكاس للجدل حول التعديلات
القانونيه بين مرحب بها باعتبارها اساسا
قانونيا لحمايه الحياه الشخصيه والسلم في
المجتمع وبين مشككان يرى فيها خطوه على
طريق قمع الحريات الصحفيه في البلاد
وتقييد حريه التعبير في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
فيسبوك
انتشرت هذه الصور خلال مناقشات القانون
للنائب المعارض بوراك ايباي وهو يحطم
هاتفه بمطرقه احتجاجا على القانون
ان هذا القانون يقيد حق الصحفيين في تلقي
الاخبار ونشرها ويمنع حريه الناس في
التفكير والتعبير عن انفسهم في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي ويفرد قيودا وعقوبات
مشحفه بحق العاملين في صناعه الاخبار
لماذا انتم منزعجون من هذه التعديلات
القانونيه الشهوان
من الواضح ان الهدف من هذه التعديلات هو
الحقول دون علم المجتمع بالممارسات
الخاطئه للسلطه التي حكمت في العشرين عاما
الاخيره وما ترتب على ذلك من اثار
في ظل تباين الاراء والجدل السياسي في
البلاد بشان هذه التعديلات القانونيه تبقى
كلمه الفصل للقضاء ليحكم فيما اذا كان نشر
معلومه ما يعتبر تظليلا يجرم مناشره ام لا
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره انقره